Easter eggs and references to other movies
have long been prominent in Hollywood, with
movies across every genre seemingly squeezing
in as many fun nods and connective inclusions
as they possibly can.Disney are famous for
it - pretty much every Disney movie ever made
has a "Hidden Mickey" in it, for example - but
that's not where such Easter eggs and references
stop.Sometimes, however subtle, Disney movies
can include things that connect them to other
specific Disney offerings and, in this video,
we're going to take a look at just a few examples
of that.
Here are ten amazing Disney movies that are
secretly connected to each other.
Finding Nemo and Monsters, Inc.
Mid and post-credits scenes are extremely
prevalent in movies at the moment, and they
have been for quite some time now, so it's
always a good idea to stick around in the
theatre after the credits start to roll.
A prime example of why that's the case came
in the credits of 2003's Finding Nemo.Just
after the "special thanks" section started
scrolling on to the screen, none other than
Mike from Monsters, Inc. makes an appearance,
swimming across the screen and giving a look
towards the camera whilst wearing a diving
mask and snorkel.
Apparently, the marine life in the world Nemo
inhabits live in the same world as the monsters
from Monsters, Inc.!
Monsters, Inc. and A Bug's Life
Monsters, Inc. and A Bug's Life share something
of a tedious connection in the form of a trailer
caravan that can be seen in both movies - meaning
the two movies must take place in the same
world.The trailers are definitely one and
the same, as they look identical to each other,
except the one in A Bug’s Life is noticeably
older and more decrepit, and is surrounded
by noticeably dryer vegetation, while the
one in Monsters, Inc., where Randall is sent
from the factory via a door, has humans in
it, is in far better condition, and is surrounded
by taller, lush grass and has a tree hanging
overhead.
Tarzan and Beauty and the Beast
In the 1999 Tarzan movie, in the scene that
Tarzan's friend Terk - the gorilla voiced
by Rosie O'Donnell - makes a mess in the camp,
there's a tea set shown on screen that looks
very familiar.
It's none other than Mrs. Potts and her son
Chip from Beauty and the Beast!And if you're
wondering how a tea set from a French castle
ended up in the jungle, consider this theory:
Jane is Belle's great, great, great granddaughter!
Look at their similar dress sense, their taste
in animalistic men, and their crazy white-moustached
dads!
It's so obvious!
Aladdin and Beauty and the Beast
In Aladdin, there is a scene in which Jasmine's
father - the Sultan - can be seen stacking
a menagerie of animal figurines that links
the movie to another Disney offering and,
potentially, to two other Disney movies as
well.Amongst the collection of figurines,
you can definitely see Beast from Beauty and
the Beast, but it could also be argued that
two of the other figurines on the pile are
Shere Khan from The Jungle Book and the crocodile
from Peter Pan.
We'll leave those last two for you to decide.
The Jungle Book and Aladdin
In 2016's live action reimagining of Rudyard
Kipling's The Jungle Book, the ruler of the
Bandar-log, King Louie - voiced by the inimitable
Christopher Walken - was presented as an ape
version of a mafia boss, and he had all the
necessary riches to show for it.
In fact, he was something of a hoarder, housing
a large collection of treasures in his temple.One
of those many treasures that he had in his
possession happened to be the Genie's lamp
from Aladdin, another Disney movie, suggesting
that the two movies took place in the same
universe.
Zootopia and Big Hero 6
2016's brilliant Zootopia is a... well...
a utopia of Easter eggs - yeah, we really
did say that - with one very subtle reference
being made to Disney's 2014 superhero movie
Big Hero 6.It's hidden in plain sight inside
the office of Idris Elba's short-tempered
buffalo character, Chief Bogo.
Hanging on the wall in said office, there's
a calendar bearing a photograph of the cityscape
of San Fransokyo, which was the fictional
high-tech metropolis that was the home of
the titular superheroes in the aformentioned
movie, suggesting that it is in the same world
as Zootopia.
Finding Dory and WALL-E
So, apparently there's something about calendar
Easter eggs in Disney movies, because another
of 2016's offerings links to another Disney
movie via a calendar.
It's in the Finding Dory scene when Hank has
Dory suspended over a massive aquarium in
a plastic cup.
There's a work station in the background that's
lit just enough for viewers to make out a
Wall-E calendar.This probably doesn't suggest
that Wall-E takes place in the same world
as Finding Dory - given that Wall-E is set
in 2805 - but more suggests that Wall-E is
a movie that exists in the same world as it,
which is an interesting twist.
The Hunchback of Notre Dame, The Lion King,
Aladdin and Beauty and the Beast
In The Hunchback of Notre Dame, there's a
single scene that manages to link to the movie
to no less than three other Disney movies
in one foul swoop.While Quasimodo is singing
the song "Out There", the scene pans out to
focus on the street he's in.
On that street, you can see Belle from The
Beauty and the Beast wandering around reading
a book, you can see Pumbaa from The Lion King
being carried around on a pole, and you can
see The Magic Carpet from Aladdin being shaken
out by a street merchant, meaning all four
of these movies are interconnected!
The Little Mermaid, Tangled and Frozen
Okay, this one's a little more complex and
is more of a theory than a confirmed connection
- but that just makes it more interesting.
The gist of the theory is this:Elsa and Anna's
parents died during a storm at sea three years
prior to the events of Frozen.
Tangled came out three years before Frozen.
Could it be that they were sailing to the
wedding of Flynn Ryder and Rapunzel?
Geographically, it works - Tangled is set
in Germany and Frozen is set in Norway, which
requires a journey across the sea.
Moreover, it is theorised that their shipwreck
is the one that Ariel explored in The Little
Mermaid.
Given that the journey from Norway to Germany
would involve sailing past Denmark - where
The Little Mermaid is set - that makes sense
too!
Cool, huh?
Toy Story and Every Other Disney Pixar Movie
There's one thing that links pretty much every
single Disney Pixar movie - and that's the
famous Pizza Planet truck, which made its
first appearance on screen in the 1995 classic,
Toy Story.
Since it first appeared alongside Woody and
Buzz Lightyear more than twenty years ago,
it has literally appeared in every single
subsequent Pixar release to date, apart from
The Incredibles - although it did make an
appearance in the video game for that movie.
It can be seen in Wall-E when Eve scans it
for plant life, in Ratatouille on a bridge
in the background of the document chase scene,
and even as an asteroid in The Good Dinosaur,
just for a few examples.
Thanks for watching our video of ten amazing
Disney movies that are secretly connected
to each other.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other Disney offerings have secret connections
to each other?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.